do you think apple will come out with a
vr headset or do you think they're just
going to go straight to ar because
everything tim cook says is like
you know tipping towards ar and if they
had vr kind of think they would have put
it out by now so yeah i think what your
games have been shipped there i think
it's uh you know i think ar and vr are
two two sides of the same coin and uh
you know technically the quest has ar in
it right you have that pass-through mode
where you can kind of lay out your
guardian and see through that's ar uh
and i think explain what that is for
people who don't know the guardian
concept and
okay yeah so so the quest has uh cameras
on it right so that it can see the real
world and that's how it knows your
position and that's how it does its
tracking right on the outside cameras on
the outside looking at the world on your
behalf yeah camera yeah exactly cameras
on the outside looking at the world
they're they're black and white cameras
they're actually i think infrared
cameras and um
you can use that to see through the
device so you get a view of what is
going on outside me you can see your
hands and everything they're just
opening up api so that developers can
use that to build experiences and when
you first put it on you use the
controller to basically outline your
guardian which says this is my safe
space it's not going to include a chair
or a couch or something that i might
smash my hand into and as my controller
gets closer to the guardian it's going
to show up in vr so that i know that i
don't want to go past this point um
so i think apple's going to come up with
the device come out with a device that
is
primarily vr focused but it has cameras
like the quest that are much higher
resolution so that you can see through
and you could see your hands you can see
other people but you know the other
people aren't they're they're not going
to see your eyes most likely is my guess
it'll be like the quest but a better
form factor where they see you know your
face is still effectively covered by the
device versus something like that that
would be cool because then you could go
to your backyard
with your headsets on
you could actually hold the real golf
club
right uh or instead of using the oculus
controllers there they could snap onto a
real golf club and you could be out
there on your back deck swinging and see
your actual friend but instead of seeing
the real world
it would then display pebble beach on
you know your deck in brooklyn in your
backyard or something that's what's
coming isn't it 100 that's that's where
we see it going is letting you swing
your actual club and hitting an actual
golf ball oh really into a net and then
transmitting that data into vr and
running the physics simulation um which
is a hundred percent simulators do i i
was saying rented airbnb that was like
some rich guys they had and
it had a golf simulator in it and like
part of renting the airbnb was this
hundred thousand those golf swimmers
cost 100 grand or something the really
good ones do they come down to five
grand but oh yeah you kind of get what
you pay for
all right and in that one it was like a
box in this room next to a bowling all
this guy had a trip down in his house
and it was like you could just hit the
ball and it it had a big projection
screen it was
interesting i mean not for me but
it so that's going to be available to
everybody in
vr slash ar
what do you call that vr
with the cameras on the outside that is
more like an ar experience that's called
a pass through
so it's a better brand yeah yeah
pass-through basically means you're
still looking at a screen
inside right you're still looking at a
screen but it's displaying what's
outside of the device it's displaying
through the cameras versus something
like magic leap where you're actually
looking through lenses so you're seeing
you know it's the same as looking
through sunglasses pass through is
looking at a screen
and then the uh you know the other
option is just looking through glass
lenses their pros and cons to each uh my
bet is that pass-through is where we'll
see the the majority of devices coming
out in terms of being ar
ar and vr capable
are you a subscription-based app or do
you just sell the app one time and then
try to get people to buy packs right now
it's just one time 20 bucks we are going
to the the wolf creek thing is going to
be our first uh our first pack so our
first golf course and where we see this
going eventually is you know i'm not
sure how into you know nfts and crypto
and and that type of thing but we really
see a lot of the things happening in vr
turning into components of this sort of
greater metaverse right where the
metaverse in my mind is is like the web
it's not quite like the internet because
the internet kind of powers everything
right and the internet doesn't actually
need a display but the web is how you
interface with the internet in a lot of
cases and i think the metaverse is going
to work like that it's interfacing with
you know the internet or whatever um
through a virtual interface and we think
the big opportunity is effectively
building out the golf side of that right
if you look at the real world nobody
owns the sport of golf
it's a sport and there are a lot of
companies that make money off of the
sport by
by contributing to it in different ways
golf clubs golf courses all that so we
want to we kind of want to set it up to
effectively give our players the ability
to sell their own packs to create their
own golf clubs to create their own golf
courses and you know structure it in a
way where we get some small
fee for doing that but so you could
actually make the game free
and then it comes with one course and
you get a ton of users and then you say
to your users listen create holes and
people can buy holes they can buy packs
they can buy challenges they can buy
clubs and we just get 10 and if you buy
this course you get an nft version of it
in other words you get to put it in your
wallet and then you could take that you
could take your golf clubs and you could
take your course and go put it in your
world on the other side of the metaverse
somewhere kind of a more compelling
process
when you look at a company like facebook
and they built they were they basically
took the open web and closed it now
they're saying they're going to
do this open it there doesn't seem to be
an open standard for vr so as a
developer you're making for the oculus
you're already locked into oculus
when apple's comes out or if you know
microsoft and google have a product that
kind of you have halo lens halo halo
lens hololens yeah hololens rather um
i think halo is a cooler name hololens
um
if you wanted to be on hololens or you
know apple's new glasses you're gonna
have to rewrite this whole code base is
going to be ported or how much can you
port and how hard is that going to be
yeah thankfully it's very easy almost
every single experience that you know
you have in vr right now is either built
with unity or unreal which are two game
engines both very very uh very well done
and ours is unity so as soon as apple
comes out or any other headset comes out
you know there are relatively few apis
that we're using that are oculus
specific and even on top of that they
have uh something called open xr which
is effectively creating this bridge
layer that will end up connecting with
all the major headsets um so it is
actually being set up in a way that is
way better than any other platform that
i've seen even from the onset um right
now it's just a you know basically 100
controlled by oculus because that that's
the only headset is there a number two
headset
it would probably be the htc vive
or the valve in index but the are those
people still investing in them and
playstation had one at some point right
yeah actually the psvr might be
be the second by the numbers but it
hasn't really done much in the last few
years uh playstation you know sony is
apparently coming out with a ps vr2 next
year that's that's the expectation
apple's coming out with something htc
just put out a new headset but it's not
really gaming focused it's a little bit
unclear what they're trying to do with
that
and then valve is you know tbd i think a
lot of folks in the space are hoping
that they they keep going with it